hello everybody i know people are coming
in everyone welcome to the march meetup
hope everyone's having a great march
we're 10 days into march
um coming up on a year on the uh
u.s side of the pandemic hope everyone's
doing well and it's healthy and is um
getting excited for their vaccines and
otherwise just making the most of their
time to get a lot of use of r or any
other type of data science or whatever
else you have to do in life
i know lots of people getting pulled
many directions hope everyone's doing
well and hopefully this meetup is a
nice respite you gotta come and have
some you know good our fun
uh so we're gonna get started in just a
few moments
we'll do our normal announcements we'll
have our speaker and i wish we could all
go to the bar afterwards but i know
that um hopefully soon uh things are
looking good in this country hopefully
hopefully the end of the year
hopefully even before around the fall
we'll be able to meet in person both for
the meetup and for the conferences
um maybe some workshops along the way uh
we'll see how the year goes but it'll be
great to see everybody again
and so everyone knows once we do go back
to uh in-person meetups uh we will do
our best to live stream it in this
hybrid format so people around the world
usually
we tried doing this a few years ago but
the audio never worked out
i think now after a year of doing remote
stuff we hopefully figured out the audio
and we'll be able to live stream right
when it's happening
in the future and of course you'll be
able to see the recordings
later but the more people we could have
joined from around the world
during the live sessions the better so
i'll get started just a few
announcements
jobs if anyone's looking to hire
we obviously can't shout out jobs in
this format
but you can go to the ny hacker slack
and go to the job posting channel
and post a job there
over the past roughly 12 years
i probably should have kept count of how
many people have gotten jobs through
this meetup but it's actually
kind of impossible it's like it's not
just through my announcements people
meet each other and they get jobs
i'm sure we i know for a fact we've
gotten numerous people's jobs
i want to say 100 on my watch that i've
paid attention to
probably more that you know just happens
without me noticing so if you have a job
you're looking to hire go to the job
postings channel and announce it
if you're looking to get a job go to the
job postings channel and look for jobs
it's as easy as that you'll find some
good people
um i know we can't do pizza together
anymore we have the pizza paul we
haven't updated the pizza pool in a year
that's really hurting me we haven't
gotten new data in a year
so tonight my pizza comes from joe's
pizza
i hope everyone has some good pizza
you're going to be eating i hope it's a
delicious wherever you're from i see we
have some people
in dublin in india and france
in seattle hopefully you all folks got
good pizza wherever you are i know it's
not new york pizza but we'll do good ah
we have some new yorkers there
uh thoughts on osmeg thoughts on de fara
i love dufar it could be hit or miss let
me say when it's miss
it's good pizza when it's hit it's
life-changing pizza
so um i recommend it it's worth the wait
i never had to wait more than like 45
minutes
and then sometimes i walk up and get my
slices in five minutes so it all depends
on where you go
we have someone from chile someone asked
for shiny up for the pizza pool
the data is freely available if you go
to jaredlander.com
data pizzapolldata.php
go to generalander.com search for pizza
you'll find there's a live feed
of the pizza pool data so please make a
shiny up of it
it was the subject of a tidy tuesday i
want to say last year at some point
so grab that date it's on
gerrylander.com data
and have at it we have some people from
london
we have uh people all over the place 1am
is too late for
1 a.m is not too late for pizza that's
like prime pizza hours
so i highly recommend 1am getting pizza
that that works for me
but people from canada with people all
over the place
all right i love this it's good to see
everybody uh garrett people are loving
your t-shirt
the r studio kong t-shirt those are
always a classic
yep all right cool northbridge
california
boston no pizza night but you could go
there's um in the north end i know the
north end can be touristy but pizzeria
regina the north van is actually quite
legit
and i do enjoy that place all right
so chicago hope you're having some
casserole to it for tonight
all right we have some pizza and beer
for somebody australia so australian
pizza it's a thick nice doughy thing
lots of toppings all right we're getting
carried away and pizza
i'll keep going but anyway if you have
good pizza shout out to me let me know
what you're eating let me enjoy it
oh asme best pizza's in new haven are
you asking for the best place in new
haven you're saying the best is in new
haven
so i tell you my favorites in new haven
but i'm not going to tell us the best in
the country
all right we're getting carried away
with pizza as me and i can duke that out
on twitter if we need to
all right so since we can't be your
person i'm loving the chat here in this
window
keep it up here in this window if you
want to chat we also have the slack
channel
the slack channel for chatting about
meetups is called
monthly meetup chat i will put them here
declaring
you and i can have a little bit of a
throw down after the whole bagel
incident too
as many said the best bagels are
montreal they're good bagels montreal
but they're not new york bagels
so if people want to chat
about the meetup or about pizza about
anything go to the monthly meetup chat
channel in slack you can ask and you can
hang out and
then you can throw shade at each other
all you want um
four questions since obviously we can't
have a question answer session like we
normally do
ask your questions in that meetup
channel i just pointed out or here in
the chat window either one
i will collate them and i will ask the
questions at the end
and hopefully we'll have some really
good questions for garrick to
show him a good time here so again if
you have questions put it here in the
zoom chat
put it in the slack chat and i will
collate them and put them all together
the video for this event will be posted
in a few days where all the videos are
there at nyhakr.org i'll put that in
here
nyhakaar.org presentations dot
we desperately need to redo this website
i designed it years ago before blog down
existed so it is markdown
it's written unmarked on a multi-page
markdown site but
pre blog down and i designed it so it is
open source it's on github
at github.com if you want if you want to
make a change
make a change make it better we are
currently working redesigning it but
you know it takes us time so if you have
something better let us know
we are happy to have someone redesign
that because
i designed it and it's just not pretty
next month may um we have an exact date
i don't know the exact date i want to
say may 17th
no sorry april oh my god it's april we
have two months planned april
i don't have the exact date um but
middle of april we have klaus wilkie and
i hope i'm pronouncing his last
both names correctly talking about using
rust from r
i'm super excited about that that's
gonna be really cool
um this is like sort of rcpp but for
rust so it's the new modern compiled
language
last month we had andy grove talking
about ballista which is written in rust
and it just so happens that we have this
nice rust thing going on
next month would be klaus talking about
rust and r so that will be
really a lot of fun may will be james
lamb
talking about light gbm for those of you
that don't know
light gbm is a boosted tree algorithm it
is a competitor of xgboost
and of cat boost um it's really exciting
depending on whose benchmarks you look
at it's faster or more accurate but
again benchmarks are benchmarks
uh sabi and may and nice thing about
light gbm it also works
on the gpu so that's really cool um
so does xg boost and cap boost um they
all work on the gpu so that's uh
it's a really nice touch to be able to
do that and even with tidy models
max and and julia's and davis's
package and i know there are other
contributors that can work on the gpu
too it's really really cool
so april we have klaus may we have james
all right
i saw someone asked about videos all the
videos get posted to my hacker.org
speaking of needing a new website
there's a bug on that website that in
order to see the link to the videos you
need to zoom out them back in
so that's not awesome so someone please
help me do a pull request
in the meantime if you can't use this
poorly built website
go just google youtube lander analytics
we post all the videos up there
that might be easier for you the meetup
videos are there as are all the
conference videos you have
six years of nyr three years of rdc and
rgov
lots of videos up there and about eight
years worth of ny hacker tons of videos
really good source
all right with all of that i think i
covered everything we have pizza we have
jobs
we have the next meetups we have the
chat windows we have questions
then we have everything so with that i
am very excited
to bring in our speaker many people here
have been using markdown for different
ways for presentations
i've been going through a whole source
of different formats and presentations
whether that was
i o slides or city slidify
or i think remark or
one of the other ones i forget what it
is even at this point i've gone through
so many but now we have sharingan
and that seems to be stolen all the
hearts of all the people
who are using it now and we have someone
who's contributed so much to the sharing
and ecosystem
please everyone give a warm virtual
welcome to garrick and i'll clap for
everybody since they can't be clapping
for you
oh thank you very much all right should
i dive in
yes please do all right so i share my
slides
um well first of all it's wonderful to
be here thank you so much jared and
the new york open statistical
programming meetup for having me
um it's a it's a pleasure to get to talk
about something that i really really
really love which
is making great slides
making extra great slides with sharingan
um so this is an actual sharingan
presentation by the way
so about a little bit about me uh my
name is garrick aiden bowie
um you can find me online at twitter at
gerk or online at garrickettenbowie.com
and um i work for our studios education
team i primarily work on
packages called greatness and learnr
which help teach
are using our markdown and interactive
tutorials
uh in my spare time i do a lot of work
uh
tinkering with sharingan slides and
building
extras and little things for them and
also i
have a couple other packages that i work
on that you might be interested in or
i've heard of like
uh themes for our studio um uh
an add-in for our studio that helps you
work with regular expressions
and an app that helps you extend
uh our studio called shortcuts so
definitely
you know check those out if you want if
you use our studio so
um i have i have the material online for
all of this
you can try it yourself again later
um i'm going to copy this link
and put it into the chat but i'm also
going to do a lot of
sort of live coding today so the idea
here is like maybe you can go back to
this
and reference it later and you don't
have you can just sort of pay attention
and and you know watch what i'm doing
but also if you if you want to have like
a whole environment that's ready to go
that has all of the art studio stuff
that you need
i built a little docker container and um
and you could use that
to just get started and drop it into an
environment if docker's your thing or if
you like docker
um so let's talk about sharingan so i
realized like i want to talk about some
cool things i built for sharing and i
think first maybe we should just talk
about what sharingan is
right so let's have a little bit of a
crash course first of all sharingan
which is pronounced sharon again sharon
gan
sharingan sharon jen i i don't totally
know
i have settled on sharingan um and it's
okay
i think everyone has a slightly
different way of pronouncing it
i'm also kind of like so so sharing
comes from uh
there's uh uh okay i don't wanna
offend anybody i it's a cartoon it has
an anime thing that i i have barely any
awareness of
um but like a lot of the things in the
sharingan package are like
um call backs to this show
that involves sharing good so uh
so that's that's a little backstory but
at the same time um everybody
has no idea so it's totally fine just
just uh lean into however you've been
pronouncing it
so how do you get sharingan the first
you basically just install it from
crayon like any other art package
installed that packages
sharing good cool and now you have the
power
of sharing again to make slides so
i think the the one thing that sharing
does slightly different than
basically any other kind of um our
markdown
um the the one way that schengen kind of
like doesn't quite
fit in with the the rest of the our
markdown ecosystem
is sort of the pathway that it follows
so a typical
our markdown document that you're trying
to convert into html
starts as our markdown uses the knitter
package to turn it into markdown
and then pandock under behind the scenes
will turn that
mark down into html and all of this is
sort of like controlled by
the r markdown package that all just
sort of happens for you
sharingan does something slightly
different and it cuts out pandock
and instead basically you take your
slides it turns into
our markdown and then um they become an
html web page but there's like the final
step of going from markdown
to html happens actually in your in the
browser
and this has a slight implication that
sometimes
certain things that you would do in a
regular r markdown just
don't work or there are extra things
that are added in sharingan that
also don't work in regular are markdown
when you're using pandoc
so i just want to say this like up front
like there is
when you're learning sharingan you are
going to end up learning a little bit of
a different syntax and we're going to
talk about that today too
so the first thing is uh is basically
let's talk about what a slide what a
presentation would look like with
sharingan
um so i have an rstudio window open over
here
hopefully this font and colors and sizes
are okay for everybody to see this
during the presentation if not just
give me a bump it up or something like
that in the chat
um so here we have uh
we have some slides this this yaml
header looks pretty familiar it looks a
little bit like the yaml header that you
would have for a regular
markdown document it has a title
subtitle author
institute date and then we have this
output
and this output format is specific to
sharing and that's what actually makes
the
the html file that turns into your
slides
okay so and then in here you're going to
write
you're going to write things that become
that become slides
and i'm going to switch back to the
slides to talk about that part so
how do you make an actual slide one
slide just one slide
the first thing is you're going to have
um three
dashes just three dashes no more than
three dashes
that's it just three dashes three dashes
on a line that makes a new slide
that's how you define a slide break
right there's some
so this sort of looks like yaml again
but this is a like
slide specific information or sort of
metadata like this changes how the slide
looks
um this changes how the slide looks or
the settings of the slide
then you have some slide content so some
stuff that you're going to put in this
slide and this is written in our
markdown
and then you can also have sort of
continuation so a really common thing
that you would do is have
uh like show part of a slide and then
like sort of pause and then fill in the
next point of the list in the next point
of the list and to do that you're gonna
use
two dashes only two dashes on a line and
that creates a
sort of small pause um and
here's here's a slide so i'm going to
switch back again to
our studio and show you what this looks
like how you would actually write this
out because it's pretty interesting
so sharingan comes with a cool r studio
add-in
i have this uh this file by the way is
demo intro
and um if i go to so i'm going to save
it
because i somehow changed it but if i go
to add-ins and i'm going to type
sharingan and there's an add-in called
infinite moon reader so what this add-in
will do
is it will render your slides
so first of all it renders your slides
and then the second thing that it does
is it will in real time update your
slides while you were typing
okay so let's try this out i'm going to
recreate that slide that i've had before
so i'm going to say
knock knock right
and then maybe i'll add another who's
there
and you can see that down here in the
preview my slides are updating
in real time so this is what makes kind
of developing
your slides with sharingan really fun
and kind of exciting if i make a new
slide
um so if i make a new slide and i say
hello over here you can see
my slide stopped updating and that's
because i have a new slide now so
to sync everything up i have to actually
save this file
and when i do there's a small render
step and now i can
jump around you can even like move your
cursor between slides and jump between
those slides i can also add i'll do two
dashes here to add a
slide pause and say
banana and i get
something like this so you can kind of
see what you're doing as you're going
just keeping in mind that every time you
add a new slide or a pause then you're
gonna have to
save your file so that you get a full
re-render um
okay so let's talk about some of the
things that would go into
the um into the slide properties
so first of all you can you can have a
class
uh sort of key that you would put so
this
class is named because it's actually
like
the html class that the slide will get
so
later on when if you start messing with
sharing and slides you start writing css
you you know you can
that that's the link is that you're
going to write a class that covers your
slide
so um but there are some that sharing
comes with uh sort of built in and that
you can use right away
so uh the first the the most sort of
important ones
are about position of the text in the
slide so you can
you can choose if you're so the default
is to have left and that would be
the kind of basics whenever you change
the slide properties you have to save
and do a full re-render again
so you can have your your text on the
left i can move my text to the right
or i can put it in the center
i can also choose whether or not it's
going to be at the top
which it already is i can put it in the
middle
and i'm saving and then i could put it
at the bottom
so if you want your text to be in a
certain position let's say
actually for this i'll actually put it
in the middle
and the order doesn't matter um middle
right
and you i think you can even put commas
in here and it will still
be fine you get the same answer so
um so these so top middle or
sorry yeah top middle bottom and left
center right these are the ways you
control
the position of all of the text on the
slide so everything that you add you
know if i go to the next
um this continuation you can see the
banana is also
on the middle right of the slide so
that's pretty cool we've we've got we've
moved our text around
the next thing is you can choose a
background
for your slide so let's say the first
thing we'll cover is background image
so to use background image um
you actually just type background dash
image and i'm gonna say url
and um i have a file here called
banana.jpg and
just once i save this and there's a
re-render and now
um now i have a background with a banana
it's hard to tell though
because uh like there's a little shadow
right here like i know that there's my
my thing changed and by the way let me
show you in the files where this is all
located so
um inside of my project this file here
is inside of demo
and then inside of demo i've got banana
and then i have this file demo intro so
my slides
are right next to to this file that i'm
this image that i'm putting in here
um this is another thing about sharingan
is you can't necessarily have your files
like all over the place like
i can reference files that are relative
to the current
that are in the directory of the current
slides but i can't go
find a random file from somewhere else
on my computer
so you kind of have to organize
everything into one folder which is
probably a good idea anyway right
okay so let's switch back and come back
here
to to our slide another property that we
can use
is background size so this is going to
control how big the background is
i'll say background size
and uh i don't know 160 pixels
by uh 160 pixels
we'll just try that i don't know there
we go we have a little tiny banana now
um so this is like i always forget which
one this is if this is like
uh width let's find out i'll make this
uh
400 so that's the width
and this is the height but really just
play with it until you get the right
size
i mean that's one way of doing this i
could also go look and figure out how
big my image is
and kind of get the the sizing right but
maybe 400 by 600
gives me close enough yeah my my bananas
don't look so great but what if i want
to have it be like the whole
background of the slide um there are two
options here
contain is one of them so my slide will
contain the image
so it basically makes the image as big
as possible until it's like out of the
slide
then um then it stops so my image is now
as big as
the background images as big as a slide
or i can choose cover
and now i am covering the entire slide
and if you're familiar with css you'll
notice these are
actually this is a css property and the
values that i'm choosing
here are css property values so
um you can you can actually go to mdn
for example
uh mozilla web docs i love this page for
learning things about css
and i could type in background image
or we could try background size
and you can click on this and you can
see here
these are these are the options that you
could use um and you're
in in this background size
business right um and the last part then
is also
background position which is also
a css property right so i can choose
exactly how the the image is positioned
and let's say i
kind of figure out 400 pixels by 800
pixels
this is a great way to get an image in
like just the right spot that is nowhere
close to
the right let's try 500
um that's maybe a little bit better i
need a i need wider
is my problem 800x500 there we go
okay this will work and now i can try
background
position and here you can again use
things like top
top left and my background will move up
to the top corner
or
bottom right and you can see these
actually kind of feel a little bit like
the same classes that we were learning
about before in terms of moving the text
around
but but very often honestly i just do
contain
i mean cover sorry i do cover to make
sure the whole slide is covered
and uh and that's usually a pretty a
pretty great way to go
um and and those are those are pretty
much the uh the great images that you
can
use for um i definitely want to
recommend
this website which is where i got this
image is called unsplash
so unsplash has a lot of awesome images
that you could use
i think if i search for banana you know
you'll eventually find something that
looks
very bananay and let's um pick out
so let me show you a little trick here
uh if you copy this you go to unsplash
you find yourself an id
or photo you like you're going to copy
that this little id here at the end
and then in this url i'm going to say
https
source unsplash.com
and i'll put and then at the very end
i'll put this
id and when i say that um
maybe it works usually it works it
doesn't it's not working right now is it
um
i have an extra there is an extra t yes
thank you
and now it'll work like sometimes you
have to actually
go to the thing
[Music]
this is the fun part about live coding
is that uh this always happens
okay we're gonna move on there's there's
a little trick there though that you can
um get yourself i think maybe if i just
go to source.com
man i use this all the time i'm not sure
why this is not happening right now
but we're gonna we're gonna back oh
there it is
so we're gonna back out of this okay
anyway
try that at home and see if you can get
it to work and then uh tweet me
about how you figured it out uh and i'll
go back to
mybanana.jpeg stick with the files that
are right here on my computer
uh very cool all right so
that's kind of the anatomy of a slide
this is basically how you build up a
slide
except we need to learn a little bit
more about what goes
uh inside i'm going to skip that layout
part but um but these
continuations are nice because you can
build up something that you want to talk
about
and show it off just one little bit at a
time
so let's talk about the con the what
you're actually going to type inside the
slide
it's markdown um and it's pretty much
like regular
our markdown or markdown that you're
used to if you've been using
r so uh this is a real quick little demo
um markdown is awesome because it lets
you
you get to like html stuff that looks
great it's nicely
um it's nicely formatted and then on the
other hand you can actually just sort of
type it out in a way that like makes
sense if you're reading
the actual uh the actual code but you
don't have to like go through the whole
process of like
remembering which tag it is that makes
something you know inline code or
emphasized or
or bold you know that kind of stuff um
and also you can have it be
rendered out into like a whole bunch of
different formats so in this case
uh we have this this sentence here the
fuzzy bunny ran
the fufu function and promptly
disappeared fuzzies italics
we have fuzzy here in italics because we
put underscores around it
we have fufu looks like code on this
side and the output because we put it
and we put backticks around it and then
disappeared looks bold over here
because we wrapped it in asterisks on
either side
so you can also make lists so you can
write a list like this in your markdown
you just put a dash and a thing and then
you put a new line and
make yourself a list which can also be
numbered
and the really fun part is you don't
even have to count our markdown will let
you
your markdown will let you just put one
and as long as it's a number you'll get
you get a nice numbered list you can
if you add by the way if you add little
spaces between those lists you can end
up with
a list that has a little bit more room
to breathe so if you um
need to make your audience squint or
want them to
uh lean forward to see what you've
written you can use this
compact version or or you can spread
everything out and let it breathe a
little bit
um you can make links links are great a
great way to
send people to go do other things and
what's actually really nice in sharingan
it will
actually uh open the link in a new
window for you so that
your slides stay right here and a link
to make a link you put the part that you
want to
be clickable goes inside of
to square brackets like uh like that
inside of two square brackets and then
the link where you're going to end up
goes
uh inside of um parentheses after the
square brackets
um also i end up using like html
things in um in markdown a lot so this
this is like a very cryptic way of
saying this is cool
um okay you can also add images images
basically are just like
links except they link to an image
and there's one little bit other other
bit that you have to put uh
uh an exclamation point in front of it
so you say exclamation point square
brackets
and then the image that you want to go
to um and you get to
like put gifs gifs are great they're
they are they work really well for
your slides uh just don't leave them up
for too long so that everyone's like
okay we've seen this and now we're
distracted by it and i can't
stop watching this kid run into the wall
this is
uh definitely me okay so
that was like super fast way of going
through our markdown
if you want uh to um
if you want to learn our markdown in
like 15 minutes this tutorial is amazing
common mark.org
help slash tutorial so i will copy that
link
and share it and um and i think probably
people are starting to notice that
there's some extra little bits
going on in my slides right now um like
those little arrows so we are going to
get to that and we'll talk about
how you can get those things in your
slides too
there's one more really big concept to
learn about sharingan
and that is uh the extra little bit that
sharing it adds or that remark ads
so technically remark is the library
behind the scenes that does all of the
take your mark down and turn it into
actual
html slides so there's one little bit
that we have to learn about
and um and that is how you make things
like this so
uh when you first start using sharing it
feels a little bit like magic
you don't really know where they came
from but you just learn these sort of
incantations and you figure out what to
do
so right now i have content on the left
side of my slide and i have an image on
the right side
okay pretty cool let me show you how we
did this
so remark and sharing again give you
this kind of syntax you say dot and then
you follow it by
some words in this case the the special
words are pull dash left
and then an open bracket so this has a
sort of marked downy feel
right but then this is the content and
it it's also marked down that gets
turned into
like pretty html um but you you write
our markdown
or yeah mark down inside of these
brackets and
um and then there's also this other one
pull right
and if you put square brackets around
something here's an image
to the the book cover and i'll switch
back and this is how you end up
with uh with content on the right pulled
to the sorry pulled to the left and then
pulled to the right
um and that's something that comes with
remark by by default it's just you you
get it and you get to use it right away
um or be confused by it right away so
like
you can uh behind the scenes what
happens is all of
so your your our markdown gets turned
into uh
html so like you have paragraphs and
here's this list that i created
but around all of that by putting the
dot
um the dot bracket and then around the
whole
this whole chunk of content this whole
chunk of content
i have um i now have a div
or so like an html container that
is has the class pull left so
this pull left basically just wraps
everything inside of it
in a container instead of a div called
pull left
and um and then pull right does the same
thing and then the browser is the part
where it gets laid out and put next to
each other
this is what i really like about
sharingan and remark is that
there's definitely a bit of a learning
curve you're going to start end up
you're going to like learn css and html
a little bit
but on the other hand um
sharingan writes like very nice and
clean html that is
pretty easy to use and pretty easy to
customize so it actually makes it kind
of fun and you're not like
hopefully you're not like super fighting
your tools the whole the whole time
so there's another way that you can do
this so i just showed you a way that
makes a whole block
but there's a way that you can make just
one little word
or one section of words special and um
so you might end up listening like this
like this word is purple
i mean the word is purple not the word
purple is purple but the word is
purple so you can make that word purple
by putting dot purple square brackets
around
word so this is like literally what you
would write in your
in your slides and um i mean you could
have written this by the way so
it actually turns into like span around
the word
and turns into actual html um
but but it's nice to be able to just
write uh
dark purple and then the thing so let's
uh let's jump back
to our our slides i'm going to
let's see i'm going to stop my the
last one i'm gonna start a new so i'm
gonna do have you guys seen this the new
command palette in our studio so i'm
gonna actually type
infinite moon reader and
start up a new one here um and i'm gonna
actually
let's see i'm gonna type out
okay so i'm gonna start with the
this thing the tail of the
flopsy bunnies all right so here we have
the taylor's lapsy bunnies
i'm going to give this a special i'm
going to put this in a special container
called
title so now the tale of flopsy bunnies
is in a special container called title
and i'm going to create i'm going to put
this in a special container purple
which looks a lot like what we were
doing before
okay now nothing has changed right uh so
what we need to do is we actually need
to write some css at this point to to
make this customized the way that we
want it
and um and this is like i think this is
one of the coolest things you can do
with uh with sharingan and that kind of
makes it sort of fun
so i can actually write a little bit of
html so when you're writing
um when you're writing css styles they
go inside of style
tags and
and then i can actually put some css in
here so i can do something like
say title.title so this dot title
is going to match this.title and i'll
put braces
open braces and then and then you get to
pick
css properties that you want to change
so for example
font size i can make it um
let's see i'll use these units in css
called
m's and it's basically like one uh
100 and then two m's is like 200 percent
and 3m
is like 300 so let's see this in action
so 2ms
is 200 3ms is 300
for so if you write it like this where
you put it inside of style tags you can
actually
update the um the css live
and um and you can see what is going on
with your styles as you're writing them
cool so i can also say font style
italic for example now i have an italic
title and what if i want so i want to
color
purple so i'll do this again right i
make a dot purple
this is going to court this dot purple
you know matches this dot purple
and now i'm just going to color this
pink
uh no not pink um orange or
red maybe make this 6m
okay we'll make it actually purple so
that our brains don't explode so there
we go
um okay so this is pretty cool uh that
was kind of fun
this is a good way to sort of practice
your css in your html and kind of figure
out
um you know what you're doing uh with
those but
you probably don't want to be writing
like you
so realistically you probably don't want
to be writing a whole ton of
css and html kind of stuff um
you probably what you want to do is like
just pick a few colors
make those colors the colors of your
slide and um and then just move on with
your life right
so i'm very excited to share with you
that
uh i have a package for you to do just
this it's called sharingan beimer
sharingan themer
and um you can also pronounce that
however you want um
and you get it by it's it's on crayons
you can install it from crayon
um and basically you're just going to
take this little chunk
and drop it into your uh your slides r
d and you can um and then you have to do
one little update
to your yaml front matter but like hang
on
that's only if you already have slides
that exist but you can actually start
from um you can actually start from
scratch so i'm going to do
under here our markdown some new file
our markdown
i'm going to go from template and scroll
through this list here
and i'll find my so it's hard to see
that but i'm selecting ninja themed
presentation
click ok and now you have a brand new
slide presentation ready to go so maybe
before we do that let me just show you
real quick
so the default for all of these things
slide z play
um so here's the default presentation
style which looks fine it looks great
it's a good starting point um
it's okay there's carl there he is again
okay so we get a feel for what what it
looks like right um so when you open up
the new themed ninja presentation i'm
gonna clean this up
and we're gonna just run i'm gonna knit
this
but i'm gonna actually need to
[Music]
make a new file name um let's see here
and when it runs i end up
in just a second this one takes a little
bit longer
for one reason okay so i end up with
let me show you the part so i end up
with a new presentation
and uh it looks considerably different
uh it's i've picked different uh fonts
for the headers and for the
the body text and um this this slide
deck is actually designed to help you
like pick out your colors pretty quickly
and kind of walk through
you know a bunch of different things
that you would normally put into slides
and would see
so let's um let's just show you how easy
this is i'm gonna go to coolers
coolers so there's this um
i love this page so i'm just going to
click on generate up here we'll make
ourselves a brand new palette let's
i don't need to be walked through the
whole thing okay so i'm going to pick
this color
i don't know no i don't like it hit
space bar let's find some new colors
that look somewhere something random
okay so i like this blue
i'm gonna copy this and i'll come over
here and make that my primary color
so there are a whole bunch of different
styles that you can use you can just
start typing once you've run library
sharing and themer you can just do style
and um which i need to actually run that
real quick and then you can do style and
see all of the different styles you can
use but i'm gonna use this one called
duo
accent and i'm going to drop that style
right here
let me pick a secondary color this congo
pink looks good
and i'll make that my secondary color
and
okay so let's uh re-knit this and
i will have in just a second a brand new
uh presentation with totally different
colors
so yeah okay there's our secondary color
it was a little bit of a different blue
or primary colors a little bit different
blue
here's our the pink that we chose let's
actually like flip this around
just secondary and um
primary just one more time
but this is a really great way that you
can kind of like get a whole
uh a whole sharingan theme all at once
and uh and kind of start from somewhere
great right
one more thing i wanted to show you over
here is it also
will automatically find so here's a gigi
plot
and this package also gives you um
a theme for ggplot that will find what
you have
in your um you know the styles that
you're using for your slides and
give you a plot that matches exactly so
it matches the fonts and things like
that
um and the colors of the the headers and
things
there's a lot more this package can do
we don't have enough time to get into
all of it but i highly recommend that
you
uh check this out um it it's a lot more
fun than writing css
if you're you know just starting out but
i actually really like reading css so
i know that i'm a little bit of a weirdo
on that so let's um
let's jump ahead again so here we go
here's the next little bit
how do you get these like extra cool fun
things into your sharingan slides
so a lot longest time ago i started with
making this
um this little add-in that was supposed
to help teachers it's a little tiny
uh countdown timer and so like you put
this up and say okay everybody you've
got
three minutes to go work on this thing
and then eventually it uh
it counts down and keeps everybody on
track and
i had a lot of fun building this and
then i started to realize like hey
there's like really cool things
you can do with uh sharingan slides and
uh and it just sort of snowballed from
there
so to get sharingan extra this package
doesn't exist
on crayon it's on um
it's on github so you have to use uh
install github to get it
it's at um g aiden bui
and get extra and the basic idea is
there's
there's sort of a kitchen sink you
sharing an extra and then you get like
a curated list of the stuff that you
probably want for everything
um or you can individually piecewise
pick out
the add-ins and extras that you want and
uh and then you just
make money um profit so let me show you
these really quick
uh we'll just walk through them really
quick hopefully the documentation can
guide you through how to actually get
them into your
into your slides so the first one is
tile view or overview
so this one when you add it to your
slides and press o
it gives you an overview of all of your
slides this is super helpful when you're
writing
it's super helpful when you're talking
and you realize like hey i'm gonna jump
ahead a little bit
you can look uh look around and see okay
this is the one i want
right it's a tile view next is editable
so i'm actually open this up editable is
a really fun way
if you're like teaching live this is
good if you're talking to a class or
doing
or brainstorming this is another great
thing so it actually gives you
it makes sections of your slide editable
now
like the editing like lives in the
browser and it will stay there if i come
back
to this slide but it won't like show up
for somebody else
and um and you can also there's a way
you can clear it so you can actually
like
check this out things that i like pizza
and things i don't like when my favorite
pizza places clothes that's a very
very sad face but for that one right
awesome
so editable is really cool um next up
panel set panel set is
a really fun way of getting more into
your slides so people you like
we end up using this a lot for things
where you have some r code maybe this r
code creates a plot
i don't want to like create a whole
second slide for this like you could
you could skip over this if you wanted
to but like we could also just sit here
and focus on it and maybe i want to
switch back and forth between the two
so it gives you a way to do that so
these are like
it's sort of like tabs in um or the tab
set and regular our markdown
and in fact panel set actually does work
in um
in general our markdown and uh and you
can actually use it in places like blog
down and other things where
uh tab set isn't already there
um oh wait also one really cool thing
about this is if it's inside of
a sharingan slide it hijacks the left
and the right arrow so
if you come into a slide with panel set
when you press the right arrow it will
walk through the panels instead of the
slides
so you can use that as a way to go
through the the slides and then it
almost feels like they're just like
extra slides for free like how cool is
this
okay sharingan share again for sharing
good
so you'll occasionally want to share
your sharing in
slides and um and this gives you a way
to
on the one hand there's a function that
helps you embed the slide somewhere in
an iframe so
put this on your website for example and
on the other hand you include it in
your slide deck and then you end up
it gives you this little bar which only
shows up if the slide
deck is embedded in another page and
um this gives you a way to walk through
slides
um going like forward and backwards
there's sharing control so you can um
click this little button and then people
can share it on you know reddit or
something i don't know
um but uh but this kind of makes cause
if you
just encounter a random iframe with
slides it could be hard to tell like
what am i supposed to do with this
am i supposed to click it i don't know
so that's neat here's another one
search i just added this last week maybe
the week before
but it gives you away you press uh
control f
and you can see this opened up the
search bar down here and i can type
things and as you type them
it searches your slides for those things
that you are typing
and maybe i look for a document and
it kind of moves through the slides so
to get this into your slides you just
have to use
this little function you drop that into
your slides pretty cool
um and then this this one i just added
this week
uh with some really big help from um
matt or kenton who
did a lot of work on this to make this
happen but you can actually draw on your
slides now too so this is called
scribble
you click this little button and you can
draw on your slides so
and then this those drawings stay there
when you come back to them later um well
at least just while you have the slides
open um and then let me show you so you
can also
uh webcam is another one you get your
webcam into your slides
for the just one last thing to show you
there are some extra things that help
you build slides
so there's a uh there's an extension
called tachyons and that brings in
tachyons which is like a whole
collection of these utility classes
and um if you have tachyons in your
um if you have tachyons it makes it easy
to sort of
like you don't have to write a bunch of
css you can just sort of like compose
things
of course you have this like really
weird thing that you have to learn so um
it has this like kind of syntax where
for like width
50 you would just use a class of w50
and um and then now i have i made that
like width of 50 maybe i'll make it with
70 and i can make it gray
by typing mid dot mid gray and i can
make it like
avenir font by typing dot avenir and i
can make it
let's see a little bit bigger and a
little bit more spread out and i'll make
it a little bit bigger
and i'll put a little padding on the
right
and then um i know i have this little
bit down here that i want to move around
so i'll do
like that like width of 30. sounds good
right i'll move this
up and what if i wanted this to be
absolutely positioned on the right
bottom there we go and i want to make
this part i'm going to put that on the
right
there we go i'll put that the text to
the right i'll make it italic
and gray and uh and now i've
just thrown together a pretty cool slide
that looks
almost perfect except i want this to be
bold
and maybe i want it to be also uh blue
so that there we go this is a perfect
slide
so um i i have a whole bunch of
resources and things and links
inside of my slides and inside of the
that webpage
that i shared and um and
would be happy you know to interact with
anyone on twitter or talk to anyone
about all of this and thank you for
letting me show you
far too many things in such a short
period of time
thank you very much i think that was a
awesome fast tour de force
um i will give you a virtual clap cause
i know other people here
i'm sure they're applauding based on
what they're saying here um
let's see yeah there's a lot of great a
lot of great questions
a lot of people just saying awesome wow
so uh
thank you uh very much about that uh
please thank you audience for liking
such but thank you garrick for that
amazing presentation
thank you so i'm gonna dive into the
questions do you have more to show
or is that everything you had no there's
more
there's so much more it's a little bit
ridiculous
yeah so the um sharing an extra
page has a whole list here are all of
the extensions that i've added
um i i just made one today while
putting those those slides together so
uh there's always new stuff coming in
here
that's great i know i've used made good
use of your packages um when i made this
question sharing i'm gonna uh
my second time at switzerland i use a
lot of your uh your packages
so let me dive into all these questions
we have um
so there's a lot coming at you um so the
first one is
let me just move this over here is there
something that we can edit
in the slide class area that'll modify
the size of the code in the slides
like make it smaller i think you did
answer this question do your things but
i'll let you have at it
yeah definitely um okay so we might as
well let me
make something really quick so like
sometimes you have r code
right and uh
quick what's your favorite function that
does something but not too much
lr unit okay
all right so here i've got uh okay got
this
so this is a i'm glad you asked because
i love showing this off
so don't look at your slides in the
viewer click the show a new window
and now you have it open in your browser
and now you can click
inspect element so i right clicked on
that little thing
and i'm going to make this so that it's
easier to see okay so i right clicked on
this code here and i clicked
inspect element and it automatically
pops up right here so you can start to
see this is like the css that's been
applied
and this remark code line i can try here
something random
like font size uh 1.5
and you can see you can mess with the
font size right there
and this is a great way to tinker and
eventually you would go okay
i need to put this somewhere so i'm
going to copy this
rule i'm going to go back to my slides
i'm going to make a css chunk so i'm
going to do
three back ticks instead of saying r
i'll say css
and i don't want to see it so i'll say
echo equals false
and i'm just going to paste that thing
right there and um
and hit save and um
and uh well i mean it should have i
don't know why it didn't update but
that generally works so i'm gonna i'm
gonna follow that one up can you do that
just for one slide
yeah no and yes so you can't do it for
just one slide
um by what i just did you have to do a
little bit of extra work
so make big uh
code so i'm going to make it i'm going
to give my slide
a particular class like big code i don't
like this make when i say actually just
big code right
and then big code class
so the big code class and then anywhere
underneath the big
code class remark code line i'll save
this and it's because i have it open
over here
but now if i come in here and click
inspect element again
you can see this rule is now being
applied so you could do that
so basically you do that first slide by
creating a class
for the slide and then having it sort of
inherit from that
great all right thank you then we will
continue on
our journey of questions um
can you source other code files in a
sharing presentation
yes yeah absolutely so it's still it's
still r there's still our markdown so
you can do
all that kind of stuff um yeah
absolutely
and some of these are gonna be random
i'll try to punch them together as much
as i can in a thematic way with
something random
um why are you running our studio server
locally
i'm running it locally so that i can
show you our studio
and switch between my browser and i
don't have to like open a whole new
um zoom sharing business
i always get lost when i happen so plus
i made a little docker container that
just has this
and nothing else so i know what i'm
showing you works
at least right now it was a good thing
to have docker going
yeah um
does let me make sure we get this right
can markdown translate does remark js
translate markdown image of side def
sizes can you specify that it definitely
the size of us of an image in a slide
yes ish i'm not sure you know what i end
up doing is i do something like this
like i
put a container around the image or
you know you eventually and when you're
using our markdown
or sharingan you'll eventually want to
do something like actually use
an image and say jpeg
and um actually use an image tag where
you can put
classes and say width equals 50
a little bit easier um
yeah but i don't know it it that's
probably one of the
that feels like a pandock thing yeah
and pandoc doesn't let you do it
typically but i often use um
i make a chunk and then use knitter
include graphics
and that gives you a lot of control yeah
i don't know if that works either
yeah that's one of those things that um
might just not quite work out all right
let's always wait to experiment
um all right let me go back to the top
here um all right
i'm missing hold on and i've
lost a whole bunch of the questions
that's okay because i have a lot and
i'll fix it
um when you're showing sharingan theme
is there a way to set the default ggplot
theme to use that theme
uh yes um but but it's really just a
a ggplot way of doing that so i think
it's set
theme and then you give it the sharingan
themer theme yeah so it's
kind of the sort of normal way that you
would
set that so there's a whole section on
the flat two themes on the package
website
and um and somewhere here it is a little
bit interesting because you do need to
use the
show text package um and at some point
so i wrote this
and then like maybe a couple weeks later
uh thematic hit the streets and um
and i was like oh man why did i spend so
much time doing this
um and at some point i'm gonna rewrite
all this to use thematic because
thematic is just amazing
can you tell me a little bit about them
not everyone here is going to know about
that i know it's came out it's styled
i'll let people know yeah so thematic is
kind of a nice way that you can
make gg plot themes so it does this kind
of thing where
um in this case i picked up you know i
made a i made a plot that picks up what
your
what styles you're using in your
sharingan slides
but um thematic does that for basically
any kind of our markdown document or for
uh any basically any shiny app too so um
or even you can even use it for picking
up your styles that you use
in for your theme in r studio and and
then
get a really nice gigi plot that looks
awesome uses the same fonts
uses the same colors matches perfectly
and it takes like
one line which also is the same thing
theme sharingan does but um theme
sharing game is basically just in
sharing slides all right so
we're going to have who wrote thematic
we're going to have a talk about it
yes yeah person's awesome carson sievert
is uh reading that one all right
carson's gonna have to give a talk here
then all right
we'll make that happen all right uh
question how do you continue
a list number from the previous slide
you had like numbers i guess one two
three four how do you have five on the
next slide
i think if you start the it should work
if you start the list with that
with the number that you want to start
with that's the one it picks up so
the first one matters the rest of them
just need to be numbers
so there's no way to automatically go
from like four to five you need to know
what ends up for
yeah yeah yeah at some point you gotta
do a little bit of
bookkeeping all right
uh let's see um this is technically a
question
what is this witchcraft
i don't know
[Music]
speaking of lists um how do you
customize a sub list like you want the
sublist item to be alphabetical or roman
yeah that one feels like very uh remark
i guess maybe one thing i would say
sometimes you just sort of have like
when you're using
markdown sometimes you have to let go of
some of those very particular things
that you want
and um but you can always fall back to
html
you could do letters for sure um and
your sub let's do a just start a aaa for
all of them i'll make it a b c d
um yeah i think so yeah and i think it
should do eyes like eyes and i
i i i b v i i think it does that yeah
yeah um someone asked them
based on what you said i'm gonna guess
the answer can you make your code
highlighting pink
can you make okay so code highlighting
is handled through
sharingan uh let me see if i have a
so there's inside of your sharingan
moonreader
has a highlight style and there's
so this uses highlight.js it's a little
bit tricky to figure out where all this
stuff comes from
but there's an option here and that you
can set and you can pick a whole bunch
of different themes
and um this might be a good time to show
the
there's a whole wiki page for sharingan
that like helps you figure some of these
things out that are more sharing and
related
and then there's a whole remark
wiki page for the remark library behind
this
somewhere in here um syntax highlighting
and there's this highlight language but
at some point i just go to
highlight highlight js
highlight js.org and you can pick all of
these
from the usage uh i forgot somewhere in
here there's a
demo where you can try all the different
themes
there it is so you can pick out from all
of these
and um it is not the easiest
thing because you have to kind of guess
what what the name is that you're gonna
like plug into the other thing
but um like i don't know like
and then you just change that here like
grayscale
yeah otherwise you have to kind of write
your own styles
when you change something in yaml with a
live the live slides update you have to
actually rebuild them if you change
something that high level
yeah you have to click save and then it
will re-render
yeah for like any of the basically it's
all the little stuff like when you're
writing inside the slide that all will
all kind of update live
also if you're there's like a certain
range of things you can do where it
updates and then there's a point where
it's like i can't i can't quite figure
this out
just save and then it re-renders and
then boom you got um you got your new
slides
and um definitely the part where you're
switching between slides
live um i think if i like
in this case like were you i don't think
i've ever run it anymore but yeah when
you um switch between
slides by just clicking around like that
is a lifesaver
uh that is pretty annoying to do
otherwise oh yeah
that's a very helpful thing um
[Music]
how did you get the bouncing arrow for
the code like when you moved your mouse
over the code a little bit
yeah so that's there's let's see where
am i
sharing an extra stuff um
[Music]
so that is i have a little page sharing
an extra
i have a little page here called it's
add
extra css styles and um
it's this hover code line is the one um
but it's a small little thing they're
little little things like that that i
keep adding
basically if i if i do something for
more than two presentations uh it ends
up in sharing an extra
because i don't want to have to remember
how to do it again it's a nice way to do
it they have to remember that you put it
in there already
yeah sorry i was trying to figure out
how i did something in our markdown
and i was searching search and searching
and i found two different people
reference solutions that i built
that no longer work that's how long ago
i didn't know
i solved it twice at one point but i
don't remember
always the best all right
continuing on um
[Music]
is there an easy way to hide slides you
may not you may not you may not want to
share you want to share but not
presented this time yes absolutely there
is
a uh there's an easy way to do that
let's say decided
like this one i can put here at the
start of the slide
exclude true and
um and when i'm done that slide is gone
done yep there's and there's even like
if you search
the issues in the sharingan uh
repo github repo there's a really neat
solution for a way that you can do this
programmatically but for right now i'll
just show you the easy way
yeah i've done something like that like
i said a global variable at top and like
then
i did like um an inline variable all
right
this one just came in i'm going to ask
you before i ask other ones because it's
fresh here
um can you create a definition box for
an academic presentation like
like in beamer yeah absolutely uh you
just have to write it yourself
all right pretty much i'm gonna follow
that one up uh can't is there like an
algorithm
uh style that you don't have to write
yourself
no there is that no can we put enough i
think
yeah i mean those kinds of things are
perfect for the the um
sharingan page there there are built-in
themes from
sharingan package directly and i have
this
feeling that um they're one of them
i think the the higgy height i'm not
sure how you pronounce that
um package or theme so it's
probably this one this has like a whole
bunch of cool things that you can
you can add um
that that probably has something like
that that sounds really familiar
so that would be i've heard people ask
for that max on your team asked about
this like i wanna be able to put an
algorithm
that was more of a book down in general
more than even sharing again
right and you you can't put i didn't
show it here but you can get uh
latex or latex math and code
or math into into your slides as well um
i don't
i don't do that that much anymore but
but it's possible
speaking of like things you could put in
here um
yeah can you switch to font what'd you
say
well i saw a whole bunch about embedding
things
in the slides like can you get a shot
from the slides like a plotly or a
digraphs or whatever yes
absolutely it just things start to get a
little weird
sometimes um so the the trick that i
would offer there is
look for there's a package called widget
frame and um and widget frame kind of
takes your html widgets and like
packages them up really nicely so that
you get just like an iframe with just
that thing
and that usually works really well but
um
and there's like certain things okay so
there's one weird thing that happens
with sharingan that kind of messes
things up sometimes
and it's really nice for presentations
but uh but not so great for
um for the html widgets which is okay so
i have this slide here
if i resize my my viewing window for
this slide
you can see like everything basically
stays the same size it just scales
up and down which is really nice that
that happens
and that's really cool except that
rescaling step breaks a lot of um
a lot of other javascript sometimes
sometimes it breaks other javascript
that's trying to figure out where the
mouse is located and so like
sometimes tooltips aren't the greatest
and other things
um but i would kind of point out also
i like i i have these slides but i spent
a lot of time jumping out into browser
windows
to like actually look at specific things
and i think that's a really nice flow in
in sharingan
and like if it doesn't fit in the slide
you know it's okay just like open up a
browser when
like another tab and uh and show it
there
um more inserting can you switch to
fonts that are installed locally or not
google fonts
yes sort of okay so
another little thing i kind of glossed
over just a little bit is that
ultimately uh okay well on the one hand
you have your slides and you're just
showing them to yourself
or like what i just did i'm presenting
them here to everybody
um but then there's this next step of
what happens after when you're going to
deliver your slides and like put them
online or make them available for other
people to see
so if it's just for yourself you can use
fonts that you have installed locally
if you're like i'm going to use my own
computer to present this and
and it's it just needs to work while i'm
showing it and then after that i don't
really care
then you're cool then everything's fine
it'll all work locally
it should be fine if you uh if you need
it to work on the web
then you're entering the world of making
it work on the web and at that point it
becomes a whole different story and
honestly like you're best off using um
you're using best off using fonts that
are already served
by somebody else on the web google fonts
is a great place to do that but there
are lots of other places where you can
find fonts
and um and i highly recommend uh like
don't bother figuring out just find
someone who
has the font online and um and go with
that
i have seen one time i recreate it once
to embed the fonts in a self-contained
sharing file
there is a way it's doable but i
remember it was not trivial
yes no not not so not so much fun
yeah you might as well print pdf that's
another great way you can do this
we just had a question can you show how
to print these slides to
including this panel set options yeah
okay so um there's another package
that's pretty new um
called what was it called uh it's called
sharingan builder
and um let me
do so oh here i have a link to it over
here so sharing builder
um it's uh being put together the whole
idea is like how do you go from a
sharingan presentation to
like a whole bunch of other stuff making
images making pdfs that kind of thing
and i highly recommend you check this
out um i contributed a function to this
i wrote a function that would
um that handles panel set and like
you know like walks through each slide
printing each slide and every panel
and then at the end staples it all
together and gives you back a pdf
and um and it actually works like really
well
um it's nice but otherwise it's kind of
a
printed pdf can be difficult uh the
other thing you can do is
for for best results definitely open
your slides in chrome
print from chrome that will usually be
the best
but i'm a big fan of firefox and um
printing doesn't work very well there
this is now going to be self-serving we
have more questions but this
self-serving people give us a lot of
sharing and presentations
please do it in self-contained it's
available now there's an option now it's
super slick now were you the only ones
who worked in a self-contained option
no no i kind of watched from a distance
all i do is make feature requests after
feature requests i contributed nothing
other than
that's not true i did a lot of stress
testing and i did a horrible solution
years ago that
made ua want to cry um everyone if
anyone's ever going to give me a
slideshow and this goes for if you go to
conferences
use a self-contained option this way
it's a single file so here's a folder
especially for us we have to host these
things at my hacker single file works so
much better please folks please please
please
single file self-contained equals true
i'm not begging you
eric you already said it to us that it
was getting self-contained
because otherwise we have to print the
pdf uh your slideshow isn't so much more
single slideshow but otherwise we have
to print a pdf and that's not
necessarily great so
self-contained folks please please
please do it
that's my my uh public service
announcement please so let me get back
to the questions
um this is a little more like an f an
academic what is the best way to include
references in slides
yeah you know that one's a little bit
tricky um
that one's a little bit tricky i don't
um i've definitely i've used like this
the site the citr cider package
um a couple other things i've made my
own hand rolled solution
i feel like i've seen this mentioned in
the sharingan wiki
somewhere um it's
uh yeah package slater yep
that's a good one but yeah i'm it's been
a long time since i've
that's one of those things that you
eventually just like uh i'll do it
slightly differently and then you just
sort of cut
there it is all right
so here bibliography and say there i was
looking for this bibliography and
citations
so there's a ref manager i've used that
too that's really nice
yeah right there you have it
um and back to inserting um can you
embed a lernar
in sharingan yeah you can i've
seen it done um i don't remember the
link at the moment
um but yeah you definitely can you have
to put in iframe and you have to do a
little bit of work to like make
things work in the iframe um
yeah but so i work on that package too
and i would love to make it easier to
put those kinds of things
into slides that's really nice
yeah um continuing sort of on this theme
how about a logo on all slides yeah you
can do that that one i
i didn't show but that's uh one of the
extensions
that uh you can actually get a little
embedded logo
on basically every slide uh just
just like out of the box like hey give
me a logo on every slide and um
and then that works so that one that
extension is called logo
it's very creatively named um uh you
might need to update the documentation
um i think somebody documentation for if
you want to hide a logo it's high dash
logo but it's actually hide underscore
logo
yeah yeah that's a good point that
tripped me up two days ago so
oh yeah right under it's i
underscore i forget i remember seeing
that and thinking i've solved it so
i underscore works but you have a
website somewhere where it says hide
dash logo so yeah i don't know i'll try
to find it again i'll send it to you if
i can find it again
oops yeah i bet it's in here somewhere
it was somewhere i'm like hey this isn't
working let me go back to my old code i
had for three months ago oh there it is
all right that's what happened to me
it's probably in the function
documentation
i think so also psa to everyone like
don't write your own package down
clone just use package down i mean i
love this website but i basically made
um it's pretty much like i have to
manually update every little piece
whenever i change things so
not the best oh thank you for doing so
that we don't have to
yeah um i'll continue onwards
um can sherigan's slides be
parameterized like
other markdown documents yeah absolutely
that's a great question
and you totally can um
yeah you can totally do use parameters
and
sharing it can you right i feel like you
can
i think you can i might i might have
done it but you have to be able to
yeah boy but what if you can't
[Laughter]
and i just said that very convincingly
but i'm pretty sure you can
really want to try it now
let's see is it going to work
it works hey yeah
yeah because it's still um yes okay this
all makes sense it's still
it still uses our markdown render so you
still use our markdown render for
everything
um what you what happens though is the
output format itself is what figures out
how to like cut out pandock from the
as the middleman and um and that's what
makes the difference
uh yes so you can totally
do something like arm markdown render
pick out these slides
uh demo intro and then i could say
params list thing
uh equals goodbye
and this is not going to work as well as
i think it's going to is it
but uh it worked and then i have to go
find the
yes intro view and web browser
there it is great parameters work
i love live testing them on the fly yeah
all right um the countdown timer is that
part of sharing an extra
no that's a separate package called
countdown
uh not on crayon but it's under uh my
github
yeah and that's that's something i go
ahead
is that that's different than the
there's a timer that comes in the
presenter now it's automatically a
sharing gun right
yes yeah so if you push p in
sharing and you get these presenter
notes and it gives you a little timer
and there is also a timer built into
sharingan itself which you can have
show on like the bottom of the slide i
think
um like it'll show here and like every
time you change the slide
it resets and so countdown from like 30
or something um
but the countdown package has uh
the countdown package has uh it's like
customizable you click it to get it
started and um
and if you can even make it play sounds
which is nice like at the end it goes
will that work in other marketing
documents is that just for sure i'm good
no that works everywhere yeah that'll
work in other places too
i was moving on to the next questions if
you had follow up you know
yeah sure um
then are there any extras for presenter
mode
so for presenter mode i have this one
that uh
like i spent a while working on this and
i was like
very excited about it um called
broadcast
which if you're so you start out by like
you open up your slides
when you have broadcast installed in
your slides it um
it gives you this so you have uh it adds
a button
to presenter mode called broadcast and
when you click it
it is supposed to give you an id
and like identify this particular like
this particular browser
and then you can share that it gives you
a link and you can share that link with
other people
and whenever you change your slides
their slides change too so they can look
at it locally
but um and then like advance with you
and you can move around
like any time you change your slide
it'll jump to the slide that you just
changed
too the problem is you need a middleman
and the middleman in this case is a
library called peerjs and the middleman
all it does is it just like
you know you have two people and it says
okay i'm gonna you guys i'm gonna
connect you and then once you're
connected you're good
but that middleman server part is pretty
flaky and at some point i would love
i mean if anyone wants to help this
would also be awesome but i would love
to set up a pure js server
that would handle all of that and like i
could run it or someone
some benevolent benefactor in the in the
community could run it for me
and uh and we could all connect our
slides
yeah i feel like a public benefit
company
would do that type of thing yeah you
know yeah
i think i know one of those one of those
people
um and then someone i just mentioned uh
maybe you want to show people how to
clone these this way they can have like
their speaker notes as separate from the
presentation
yeah so if you're let's see you press c
to clone and um firefox is going to yell
at me you probably won't see what
happens next
i'm going to say allow
wait wait wait am i i'm just going to do
it again press no stop
let me out uh
how do i get come on just let me okay
anyway the point is you have to finish
fighting
fighting your browser um it will let you
it'll create another window and then
those two windows just on your computer
will talk to each other
so you press c to clone and then once
you've cloned
then you um then on one of those you
pick one to like share with everyone
else and then you look at the other one
and you can press
p on the other one and see your
presenter notes
um i i have but i've also
like doing this for large workshops um
and other things using sharingan in the
end i usually show my
own screen and uh and don't because it
just ends up being too confusing like
which which one is one that people are
seeing and
um it gets hard to debug quickly so
if you really want to i use the notes
all the time i'm always dedicated screen
separate that's you know everyone
has different things um
then there's a question okay you sort of
you've seen
yeah i saw a couple that kind of pull
off of that which is
how do you if you want to figure out um
like what things can you do
uh they're question marks so typing
question mark will show you
this doesn't look so great let me find
another one uh
question mark here that also doesn't
look so great
[Music]
where is all right question mark here we
go so when you do question mark it will
show you
uh a list of keyboard shortcuts that you
can use there's like a bunch of other
things you can do
um like um making your slides go
backwards
which is hilarious um
but okay and then the other one so
that's a help menu the other one
is how do you get um presenter notes so
if i want presenter notes for this slide
about my about the banana i'm gonna say
like
this you you put so instead of the three
dashes to create a new slide
you're gonna put three question marks
and now you're kind of like attaching
presenter notes to this section of the
slide and i'll say um
this is a joke that most people
know
and then demo intro let's
see okay and then if i go to that slide
and press p um those notes show up right
here
which is uh which is pretty cool and
pretty helpful
but again if you if like if you uh if
you're sharing your slides
um at the same time if you're sharing
the same screen that you're like
presenting with
then uh then that makes it kind of
that's kind of hard to do
so balances and treatments
oh yeah that's why i like uh notes this
way i can have those funny jokes myself
do they laugh at me or with me
yeah but also i guess it is a good thing
to do
i should point out too that it's good to
do for people who are going to look at
your slides later
like they can come through they can hit
p read the slides and you know as you
like move through it you know
and then they can see what you're let's
see
see what you know what you were going to
say
yes
oh yeah and it's like when you have an
incremental slide the notes show up
incrementally also that's a nice touch
yeah except they like kind of stack on
top of each other
which is what the content does as well
so the content stacks
and the notes stack too so you know i
have the
notes from the first part of the slide
and then the notes from the second part
um yeah and you know in general it can
be hard to get like a ton of stuff in
here but it's you know good for
reminders
a lot more space than i have slides that
had almost no space
yeah all right um we'll have a few more
i know we've been going on for a while
um is there a way to make a save
template uh like you always keep doing
the same exact stuff so instead of
copying and pasting you know
make a template for yourself yeah
definitely um and i highly recommend
doing that because
ultimately you're going to want to write
so sharing and themer can write out a
csv file or css file
for you right so like it creates a css
file you you might want to like just
carry that css file around instead of
the the actual code or something like
that um
and the the best way of doing that is to
create and then
well okay so first you have to create a
package which uh
sounds like a lot of work but it it's
you know it doesn't have to be like
earth shattering and also you don't have
to share it with anyone really you can
just put it on github
or share it with yourself and then
inside of that r package you're going to
create a
template and our markdown template
and um and and then that way you can
make that kind of happen i was wanting
let's see
there's probably a thing in the like
definitive r markdown guide
about templates um but then i don't
have off the top of my head
here we go here it is yep
so i'll share that with everybody so
that's actually how um that's how for
example i made a template that is
uh my
see when i do new our markdown document
that's how i have a template here called
uh
ninja themed presentation and that's how
the sharingan template is
shipped as well so
yours almost always answers yes um
let me just wrap up those last few um
someone's having trouble getting code
highlighting you sort of went over this
you might just say tell me you went over
this
um can you show us customization options
for code highlighting and how to
do code highlighting when you're using a
special theme i guess that goes back to
the whole
yeah let's see so i think on second
thought i think what we're talking about
is something that this might take a
second so somewhere in here
so you can um
i don't know if i actually included it
in this
so there's a there's a way that
sharingan gives you
to where'd it go do
let's try this one so let me find this
in my slides
um so here
and um i'm gonna just scroll this over
okay so
there's a way that you can highlight
individual lines of code and kind of say
like okay i want you to like focus on
this right now
like if i want to have a part of my
slides that's saying
we're gonna focus on um on gapminder
so i'm going to put a comment at the end
and then two carrots
kind of like two little eyes looking in
that direction and
when you save this you'll get a line
highlight
so the default is to make it like this
bright yellow color
and um and then so in
sharing in themer i think we can change
this by saying so
all of these next time show off that
there's like a ton of different options
here for
sharing and themer so this is inside
this like style function
and you can kind of like just look
through all of these things
and find what you're looking for in this
case we want to change how
code looks and we want to highlight it
so
code highlight color is going to be the
thing that we're looking for
and then at this point then you have to
pick something
and um i'm just going to like guess at
some rgba
guess at some colors like very red
and not much else but
very low alpha
and when that updates
we'll jump back here so there we go we
have a new
line highlight color or code highlight
color yeah great hopefully that answer
that person's question
um the handwriting notations on code for
some of the slides is that done a
scribble
yeah no so i uh i have yeah so i
often what i'll do is i'll take a
screenshot of the slide
something like this i'll take a
screenshot of it send it to the ipad
draw on it on in like um what do i use
goodnotes
something like that and then um send all
of those
drawings back and then put them in as
background images
so that's uh that's the whole process i
cheat uh
entirely but so you can see it kind of
like here's the original
and i can interact with it because it's
actually code and then
here's the image and uh you know
if it happens quickly enough you don't
even notice
but you can see i messed up the i
changed the slide number after i did
that so
oh yeah brutal
right that that's the kind of little
detail that i'm like
but i am not going to fix that no i
don't blame you
that's someone just that was someone
photoshopped it not that's fine all
right
um can you publish sharing inside our
studio connect
i yeah yeah i think so you get it yeah
cause like everything goes to
connect connect and handle anything yeah
connect's amazing
great great product it really is
um can you add an image inside a panel
and have it cover the whole panel
like a background size cover does
yeah yes absolutely and
yeah whoever asked that question
basically sketched out
the how you would do that too so you
would
um we could like where did my thing go
where is your
your where's duty hauser um
this guy all right
[Music]
sorry i have like keyboard shortcuts to
do so this thing what if i make
uh all right i'm just gonna
open this and a new thing and look at
inspect element and so i have this span
right here uh
something like this
okay here's what we're gonna do so i
have this thing i'm gonna give this
this is i'm gonna get rid of this image
because i don't need it
and then i'm gonna get rid of all this
stuff too so
just i'm cheating to just jump straight
so i have this div i need the div needs
to have a height
uh and a width so i'm gonna make it like
400 pixels tall
and you can't see it but there it is and
then
background image is going to be
doogie.jpg and you can see now i have a
doogie
there and it's repeated but i can do
background
size cover and now i have just doogie
and i could kind of like
you can fiddle with this more and
position
um css
yeah it's going to need some css like
that looks pretty cool
and then at this point you uh copy this
rule
go back to your slides and um
and drop it in i'll call this like duty
get rid of that stuff in the middle and
[Music]
make a little oops
echo equals false
and we're back
wonderful just like that but yeah
that's the basic idea make a div put a
background image on the div
cover it and it's just like a slide
except it's smaller
but the what is needed there is it needs
to have a width and a height
to make that work you didn't put a width
in there
oh i did i cheated because it's actually
here in this class
yeah but um but you could also do with
30 percent like that and
um come on back dude there we go
nice yeah all right then we'll call this
the
last one i know we had a lot um
can sharingan work as a shiny document
as a regular app or as like an html
document
that we could publish on shiny apps that
i o
no no no so that's where
yeah what's that can't do runtime shiny
no no i don't think uh yeah i would be
amazed if that worked
and i would love to hear about it but i
don't think so um
because the problem is like sharing or
so like underneath so this is where you
get into like that it's not our markdown
anymore it like comes out
as a um as remark and like
some weird stuff happens in the browser
basically if you like try to look at
the slide file like if i find the actual
html
and open this in the editor um this kind
of gives you a sense of what you're
looking at so you have like
there's a bunch of stuff that like sets
up your slides and everything and then
you have this big text area and you'll
notice this is basically
your um your mark like what you wrote in
our markdown but it's turned into
like not armor just regular markdown and
um and and then
when you load this in the browser remark
goes in finds that text area
processes the markdown and turns into
actual slides so
like if shiny somehow magically worked
in there i would be amazed yeah
i agree that'd be tough this isn't real
markdown all right
one more question came in i'm going to
let it slide in um it's not really
sharing this is actually useful
the command palette shortcut how do you
get it to work in firefox because that's
the shortcut for
incognito window yeah yeah control
control shift p and it comes up so this
is where you
this is where i practice my um my
windows
keyboard shortcuts because that's
usually what it falls back to in the
browser
um but yeah that like i do that all the
time
i i like i actually before i presented
just now like practice bringing up the
command palette a few times so that i
had the muscle memory because otherwise
i always end up opening a a new private
window and you're like ah
all right then this is since you
mentioned a keyboard this is because the
people want to know they want to know
about your keyboard switches on that
clacky mechanical keyboard
yeah right yeah i am i i just like i
just
got into the world of mechanical
keywords so i started out with um
a kikron and um and
uh and i thought like hey that's so
silly like who wants
like led lights that change colors when
you're typing and it turns out
i do very much i love it
it's so nice yeah i just got now i just
need to find a good like
a good wrist rest because uh it's too
high
go split keyboard get one of the ones
like the split keyboard has a wrist rest
built in
i just went split keyboard this week
huge difference has a wrist rest built
in and
the keys angle downward properly uh it's
a game changer
yeah all right yeah when i i'm i'm about
to get bit by the bug i think so
oh yeah thank you all right so
um thank you very much that was
wonderful you guys are almost spent
almost as much time on questions as you
did on the presentation maybe more so
thank you for that
everyone a big virtual round of applause
in the chat window for garrick that was
a fantastic talk
i'm doing a little golf clap for you
hopefully that's um
loud enough for you sorry to have a real
audience here so everyone the talk will
be up
on um ny hack r within a few days
remember we have the april meetup we
have the may meet up
they'll be announced very shortly um
coming up soon
and just everyone thank you very much to
garrick that was fantastic i hope
everyone had us a good night and i'll
see you all next month
bye everybody bye everyone thank you so
much
thank you garrick